je rappelle que la pitié pas sa
troisième position au niveau de la bouée
du comité martiniquais du tourisme à 7
minutes mais c'est le final on est dans
la dernière ligne droite pour le
vainqueur de l'étape et c'est rosette
qui se présentent dans le final et et ab
sport rosette/orange chant qui n'ont qui
va essayer de remporter cette étape mais
il ya aussi timorés énergie oui mais il
faut laisser la lab c'est de jouer
normalement italie peut-être qu une
erreur de poing coups c'est louis jeu
libye était laissée à bâbord
cette bruit et a marqué à laisser à
bâbord donc il fallait enfin d'après ce
qui est écrit doit nous le 7 juillet
talent ici à bâbord bon on va avoir un
commentaire après il fallait normalement
la laisse et de l'autre côté mais bon
les yoles sont en train de se contrôler
pour le final de la ligne d'arrivée on
laisse on oublie cette petite béquille
face au public il fallait la laisser à
bâbord à elle c'est de l'autre côté
elles sont passées dans les sessions du
bord et elles vont directement la ligne
d'arrivée encore on va était assise au
ca avec le comité mais c'est pas
tellement grave là on est en train de
finish laguiole est en train de virer
elle va se retrouver d'abord à mieux
vous n'aurez peut-être il aura mieux
elle va se retrouver d'abord à muret
laguiole qui vient de l'autre côté qu'on
ne voit pas bien sûr les grands voiliers
et ne prend pas encore le vent laguiole
tribord amure laguiole tribord amure
priorité
et voilà coulé et laguiole ce qui m'aura
murs et lier ce même si vous venez rejet
qui va suivre va terminer avec okami je
vous l'avais dit on ne viserait pas une
matinée tranquille voilà voilà voilà
elle a coulé sur la ligne d'arrivée
alors là c'est compliqué il va falloir
mettre la 32 mètres carrés est arrivé
avec la troupe de mètres carrés je ne
pense pas qu'elle y rosette/orange ira à
la plage quand je bois
elle va terminer avec 82 mètre carré par
rapport au retard qu'elle avait voyons
en couple ligne d'arrivée tranquillement
tranquillement pourquoi parce que
l'adversaire était terminée le vent
avait petite faute d'inattention petite
rafale qui vient de la terre petit
rafale le souhait faire de fausses et
lui a dit saleh et la victoire deux
semaines peabody energy la victoire dans
celle de la persévérance
parce que c'est vrai les coéquipiers de
jean jean louis l'agît se sont bien
battus et ils sont récompensés de leurs
efforts avec une belle victoire d'étape
à fort de france on n'a pas des rosettes
et bien c'est ce même thibout d'énergie
qui met tout le monde d'accord
consultant doctor death à l'alto rosette
vaut être immolés cas où les essais des
petits bugs énergie qui remporte cette
étape la dernière la plus populaire du
tour
on attend maintenant de toi yole tels
que sap étiquetté troisième tout à
l'heure à plus de sept minutes et demie
qu'elle regagne à revoir et salades chez
un coup à droite un coup à gauche dans
la visible dans la favela laguiole
prendre l'eau est cool on ne maîtrise
pas parce qu'on ne sait pas d'où vient
le vent tourne souvent ensemble et puis
l'autre volcanisme un petit bout des
digues l'énergie qui n'a fait que bordés
savoir éviter la gueule qui appelait le
vent est coupé la ligne d'arrivée en
grand vainqueur alors nous attendions fn
champions nous attendions gère des
appétits la pelouse est on avait
commencé à tendre aux êtres connais ni
malade ni c'est vrai marqué par beaucoup
de dessins lac bloom energy c'est un
grand patron en interne tout à leur
demandait de
hommage au bâton mais voilà un grand
patron monsieur georges henri lagier
avec johan jacka a bien sûr la ligne
d'arrivée avec la victoire des
springboks énergie de la ville de foix
fois
à
ah ah
même google energy de france soir qui
s'imposent on attend maintenant la
deuxième violent allait rosalie vous
êtes vous nous sommes avec un jab et
jableh ça fait tilt appaloosa pour
l'instant tout le cas on ne célèbre pas
qu'on ait la victoire et donc des taux
concentré jusqu'au bout vigilance
jusqu'au bout c'est ce qu'a demandé tout
à l'heure donc at on donc aux coursiers
et également à son fils et à ses fils
loïc locaux qui sont dans la datation
parce qu'on a vu ce qu'est au louis qui
se cache
loïc qui se passera ce qu'il veut virer
il dirait attention ils vont virer et on
sait également que un rose est rouge à
dessaler donc tout à l'heure à la fois
jeu de l'arrivée et les jeunes docteurs
franciscaine de cet équipage donc le job
les appétits l'appaloosa bas et fait
tout leur temps voilà tranquillement il
s'applique pour pouvoir docker à
franchir cette ligne d'arrivée à fort de
france en 2e position
parce qu'effectivement ils ont devancé
monsieur marc gaillard notre deuxième
position au fond de france pour les
jeunes donc de jablé appétit l'appaloosa
accompagné notamment par un bateau
suivant c'est le fan club également donc
de l'équipage donc j'appelais ça petit
lapin louça qui est reparti aia qui eux
et ils ont pris tout leur temps à temps
sur la mecque la rafale a tenté un
putsch et b voilà donc vigilance et oui
c'est ce qu'a demandé donc à tôt
d'ailleurs il montre de la mer donc à
loïc
la position a peut-être de dans oz t il
en montre un peu la direction à prendre
mais voilà donc pour les conseiller et
donc de jablé les appétits l'appaloosa
qui vont arriver donc dans quelques
instants
six ou sept plages de la française voilà
le final maintenant l'arrivée de l'aïe
les appétits j'appelais l'appaloosa qui
doit résister aux rafales je rappelle
que rosette qui faisait figure de
vainqueur à coups les plus violents
coups les d'ailleurs dès le départ donné
du côté de la française ont dessalé
tremblay s'était dm liège transport beau
visage qui est sa 4l royal ufr chanflor
d'ailleurs l'image du fn showfloor lui
ai fait un show floor qui est en 12e
position puis fr showfloor qui se dirige
vers la ligne d'arrivée en reste avec
vous jean l'arrivée maintenant du
vainqueur du tour à savoir appétit
j'avais là-bas nous à ça pétille j'avais
l'appaloosa qui va à son tour franchi la
ligne d'arrivée en deuxième position
attention quand même aux rafales que dit
babeau sur la ligne d'arrivée
oui voilà semaine d'arrivée vous voyez
les supporters de rosette orange
encourage loriol vient dessalée
à deux mètres de l'arrivée
malheureusement mes amis voilà laguiole
remontèrent ils voient leur gueule juste
en face et laguiole qui est en train de
repartir et les supporters rentrer
carrément dans l'eau pour pouvoir
acquérir lauriane alors faites vite
information serait un petit peu
d'énergie qui a passé la ligne d'arrivée
est reparti parce qu'il avait du mal à
rentrer dans cette danse est rade de la
française sur cette plage de la
française tente un petit peu d'énergie
et brebis et on va voir ce qui se passe
parce qu'on ne comprend pas trop ici ce
qui se passe sur la plage voilà rosette
autre temps a repris la course ce genre
oui j'ai l'impression que je suis un
petit bouc énergie on parlait de la
bouée attribue aussi le pop ou été
respectée à mon avis elle n'a pas passé
la bouée trudeau l'appel cet idiot le
site laguiole bouzid ont léché l'abri
sur tribord et le parc uhuru diba bon je
vous avez vu les fonds café geab les
appétits l'appaloosa pour passer la
britannique où il a laissé sous le vent
c'est tuer la vie et le parcours
correctement les deux autres viols à mon
sens n'ont pas passé le parc où on en
voit passer la bouée voilà c'est lequel
est indiqué dans le temps coule le plan
coup et réécrire le poing coups indiqué
bruit à l'itie abba bombe à bord de
l'autre côté et ce même va virer va
retourner pour vire en à lui faire
remarquer va retourner pour vista c'est
extraordinaire de voir renadhoc c'est la
gueule qui a obligé appétit la page et
aller l'assassinât par les arts qui
remporte l'étape à ce que ces deux lions
sont en train de repartir on a dû leur
dire moi je vous disais que on a
toujours ce souci aime les instructions
mais là les instructions colle au parc
où il faut laisser la boue et abat bon
que nos téléspectateurs comprennent la
bouée doit être passée en plus aux
patients entre la bouée et la terre elle
vous avez raison de ses appétits gerber
la parole de l'ap à lausanne
c'est vrai parce qu'il ya tellement de
choses qui se sont passées et vous allez
expliquer tout cela à péter gerber
lapanouse acquis
l'étape et le tour de martinique des
yoles un pari réussi donc pour les
fromages s'ils sont heureux
trente ans après le opère à thomas
joseph masse gagne en 1986 avec caresse
antillaise
trente ans plus tard eh bien les fistons
masse guette le tour et succède à fixes
mobiles durcis un choc lors la joie de
laguiole du françois zapetti gerber
l'appaloosa sabri qui a remporté cette
saison je le rappelle le championnat de
martinique trio loin et le tour ça
pétille gerber l'appaloosa champion de
martinique et fait qu'un but aux jo tout
doux il ira mieux je suis sans voir je
suis sans voir parce que quand on voit
des désirs nos tactiques comme ça à ce
niveau de compétition
c'est quand même assez extraordinaire et
ça offre à ces jeunes le même s'ils ont
besoin d'elle le père à côté qui le dit
pas fait attention pas refait le
parcours est tombé là qu'il a dit ou pas
passer mon côté j'avais vu que laguiole
à piper à la pipe et ils ont fait
déborder la vente faut passer pour
passer selon l'ap hm billet j'ai eu à
l'école moi je les regardais et je
savais qu'il passait la bouée dans le
bon sens positif
c'est tout à fait extraordinaire ce que
nous avons vécu aussi bien de yole qui
foulent ils passent pas la bouée mais
nous avions quand même permis si le sol
est bien en milieu de semaine
bien aussi c'est un de mes pronostics
voilà vous avez avancé donc la victoire
finale 2 appétit bien jouer deux mètres
plus tôt elle à valence et à 3 jours la
victoire de sa pt j'avais l'appaloosa
c'est chose faite
alors attention attention mutuelle mare
gaillard je vois des hommes note
l'arrivée de l'étape sap et hijab et la
pelouse a fait d'une pierre deux coups
la victoire d'étape et l'auto et oui
parce que ce petit bug energy avait
franchi la ligne d'arrivée et vous
rappeler qu'il y a eu durant le parcours
oui je les dis tu l'as passage ne pas
oser dire pourquoi on ne critique pas
que la passion mauvais sens mais ce
n'était pas ce qui était indiqué sur
l'époque où le parcours indiqué qu'il
fallait laisser la bouée à bâbord ça
voulait dire qu'il fallait le passé
entre l'amour et la terre le fort saint
louis par exemple et ses deux fils
violent comme j'avais pu voir les roses
et oranges et la young energy sont
passés sous le nom d'abou et donc moi je
le fais toujours comme jeudi des
commentaires de ce que je vois
voilà et mutuellement gaillard de la
ville de ducos avec tu marques l'ag qui
termine à la deuxième place de cette
étape foulard grand tout ça en avons
accueilli babeau silice est possible de
26 pour lui tiennent d'ailleurs
l'ambiance sur la ligne d'arrivée kelly
babeau les supporters sont en train
d'accueillir en coupe avec du champagne
les rigueurs de ce tour
on essaie le plus rapidement possible de
se rapprocher de lui
abbas
oui
ah ah
on ne fermera ce week-end ronde et belle
victoire est un label et abandonna avons
tout donné après y'a cfa rouler devant
nous on a su j'ai eu
on a su être patient répond à cause
d'une heure au départ vous d'aider leur
avons organes l'étape mais c'est pas
beau boulot
avant tout
mais on emballe aujourd'hui ça se fête
c'est à 14 soit toujours
l'abbé salle à l'occasion mais bon je
pense humblement pierre dit
on attend monts et d'avoir réussi
justement apporter son plein soutien de
mes enfants de les enfants qui sont
soulagés je remercie tout le monde qui a
soit avec mes enfants et je vais faire
demain
les jumeaux et j'aime les tubes
oui on attend les mots sont ici à
l'arrivée des frères jumeaux voilà vous
l'avez entendu et de leurs équipages
d'abedi gerber la balzac
je m'appelle de quotas après le père
joseph mars en 1986 caresse antillaise
gagner le taux est bien trop tôt après
le opere les jumeaux loïc et laurent
remporte le tour il ya 30 ans josette
pas ce qu'est le tour et bêtement en
2016 et bien la victoire des jumeaux ils
ont aussi remporté le championnat de
martinique à l'autre tant il ya eu les
arrivées parce qu'il ya eu un
cafouillage extraordinaire gens on a vu
la yole smartbook énergie franchir la
ligne d'arrivée mais il y avait une
erreur de parcours
ensuite ces appétits qui a vraiment
gagné l'étape avec deux minutes 26
secondes sur virtuellement gaillard 3e
ce petit bouquet logis à 2 59 4e vous
êtes à 3,07 quatrième digicel à 3,45 et
5e a eu des stocks à 4,16 alors sur ce
cafouillage gens pour bien éclairer nos
téléspectateurs car ce même bâtiment
énergie a franchi la ligne d'arrivée en
première position
mais problème de barre au problème des
parcours après la bouée qu'il était
situé au large la toux luminar il
fallait aller au bout et qui était
située 10 devant un public un peu plus
loin au milieu les devants public et il
fallait les 6 es doué à bâbord donc je
vous ai dit que l'indication des babors
bâbord c'est à dire en 3 labourer la
terre mais nous avons bien noté que les
lieux passait à l'extérieur de la baule
qu'elle est d'abord sur la ligne
d'arrivée avec mutuelle mare gaillard
avec un partage et belle performance
aujourd'hui vous avez tenu jusqu'au bout
la fête de cette course et vous avez
réussi un tour de force
deuxième wii avec un beau débat j'ai
toujours qu'il y avait toujours du modem
et bonhomme de données trouver un à 20
pouces ce matc des chaussettes
malheureusement mais on n'a pas pu
accélérer
donc on a contrôlé jusqu'à l'arrivée
mais j'ai constaté que les confions à
l'avant eu des problèmes donc c'est tant
mieux je félicite le vainqueur
en l'occurrence serait d'opter aux
appétits ce sont des jeunes qui ont
beaucoup envie de cette victoire et qui
va vous être l'avenir de laguiole
maintenant entre des anciens dont nous
sommes allant gagner les jeunes à faire
de même
estelle ailleurs l'opérateur le plus con
jours n'avaient pas démérité en tout cas
cette année c'est vrai que cette année
on était préparé pour faire partie du
podium mais on a eu un à paris sévère en
passant vers sainte anne je profite de
votre salut emilie et humain notamment
qui sont de grands malades et j'espère
que le bon dieu va faire le nécessaire
pour y rétablir
je félicite mes gars ben aujourd'hui
parce que c'était pas facile on avait un
imposant de voile avec l'elysée qui
augmente et donc on a limité les dégâts
n'ont toujours pas qu'on finit deuxième
c'est tant mieux pour à venir et bravo à
monsieur le maire est mutuelle mare
gaillard 2e à la française donc à
fort-de-france à 2,26 point fr jean
flores qui vient de virer la bouée du
comité martiniquais du tourisme
donc on va virer cette bfr champfleur
laguiole du robert on rappelle les
positions donc sous la ligne d'arrivée
puisqu'à l'arrivée de cette étape riche
en rebondissements ufr champions à
l'image à tous les autres y en avoir des
salles et ctd mdf de la ville du
lamentin transport boniface du robert
jef à coups de pelles de la ville
du robert royal notre unité mais aussi
tremplin qui a longtemps mené qui avait
mené qui a pris le meilleur départ et
voici c'est derrière edf qui a aussi
joué de malchance
ensuite rosette et est en passe de
gagner cette étape est bien rosette a
coulé avant la ligne d'arrivée et on n'a
pas encore tous favoris logiques qui a
vu dans la première place et oued aussi
et vous êtes et docte ce petit bourg
energia dubois venir pour passer dans le
vrai sens la ligne d'arrivée et la
victoire pour répéter gerber l'appaloosa
qui fait d'une pierre deux coups la
victoire d'étape et la première place au
classement général au temps avec 2,26
habituellement gaillard de ducos de ces
capteurs sur ce même débauche d'énergie
du françois 4e et à l'espoir aux échos
orange à 3,07
ensuite nous avons digicel à 3,45 six et
validé stocks du marin à 4,16 et 6e
express à 6,37 kelly babeau
hier j'en saurai quelle erreur quelles
erreurs on en veut dire mais pourquoi ça
se passe quand on était euphorique on a
vu que la victoire de l'as lattes en
charge de tout donner
on n'a pas à juger de papa sur la vo 18
c'était bien parti vous avez bataillé
dur optique la course aujourd'hui qui
n'était pas facile on a dit qu'on est
capable comme ailleurs capable faut
qu'on achète
la chose était là mais là il a lâché au
dernier moment on ne peut qu on nous
critique et que tu n'as pas que c'était
ce à laisser à tribord alumina là bas
aussi
voilà mon goût de la victoire et de la
fusée peut pas lâcher tout le monde tous
les téléspectateurs tous les enfants
pour qu'ils soient donnés ne parle qu'en
bon jour à tout le monde le corps mon
coeur est pour la montée olharan je
m'appelle également si j'en lis la g
totalisent 8 victoire finale félix
mérine comme battront logique qu'au
final ce monsieur que vous venez de voir
jeanjean village et à 11 victoires
d'étape
de fait aux victoires concernant les
tours je dis bien hausse victoire finale
au change en village et parce qu'il
était confiée sur monoprix et de doillon
note 11 victoires finales pour changeant
lula j un sacré monsieur il a terminé je
le rappelle avec ce même de thibaut
pinot logis aujourd'hui troisième à 2,59
à seagate discount qu'il s'apprête à
franchir la ligne d'arrivée gens se
disent que nous leur fournissons une
fois que les yoles de tête ont des
petits soucis que cela arrive surtout
dans un parcours comme ça on navigue à
vue on ne promet pas d'erreur c'est une
navigation un peu spécial dans la bci
navigation extraordinaire parce qu'on a
des vents changeants d'aller
éventuellement on a les vents de force
différentes de force et de direction
mais c'est vraiment extraordinaire le
pouvoir et gatineau cette bête surtout
pour le public mais monsieur qpc que
nous regardions la chance et les gens
qui sont sous lé monde les auteurs
peuvent vraiment voir la régate aller au
pied à l'argent c'est fou ce qui s'est
passé ces fonds avaient dit en
présentant cette étape ce sera une étape
riche en rebondissements
eh bien on a du biscuit on a des
biscuits avec des rois baudis pardon
on a des biscuits mais tellement alors
en semaine de 15 pour diageo scott kelly
sur la ligne d'arrivée
oui nous sommes avec caraco au calva
l'image quelle belle image de de francis
kahn le mas et accor qui sort il se
console wii qui se félicite plutôt je
dirais belles images belles images à
convoyer envoi il ya des émotions mais
quel dommage dessalage à quelques mètres
de la vie de la whey c'est vrai on
voulait gagner fini en beauté il manque
d'inattention et comme le mentionnait
beaucoup parce que c'est la victoire et
on a des salles et vêtements c'est des
choses qui arrivent
ça va nous permettre de mieux travailler
pour l'année prochaine ne peut plus
concentré ça fait mal mais c'est une
fonction qui gagnent c'est bien c'est
bien
oui oui oui c'est bon aussi c'est bon
parce qu on gagne pas mais on prend la
2e place du 100 c'est bon pour moi
alors y at on m'a sauvé c'est l'heureux
dangereux nathan masson la boue
élection face à cette victoire la
victoire de ses fils voilà donc vous
nous donnez l'interview de joseph parce
que je le rappelle avait gagné son
premier tour en 1986 30 ans après ses
fils gagne le tour donc aussi la
dernière victoire de laguiole dr ruth
qui est maintenant un appétit et bien la
dernière victoire remonte à 2008 avec
joseph basse dont huit ans plus tard et
bien appétit succède donc à dr roots on
adopte un polissoir de laguiole
concernant le palmarès du tour de la
martinique des yoles rondes et bien
l'équipage de zapetti gerber l'appaloosa
succède donc au palmarès du toa ufr
chanflor kelly babeau avec à tomasz
alors attends fierté de voir vos fils
gagné trente ans après vous leur avez
donné le flanc bois ils ont finalement
réussi
oui effectivement bon ben là de la
grande nation m dames super heureux
satisfait de mon travail que de longues
années et après 3,1 effectivement jean
la victoire l'année dernière j'avais pas
mal mais j'ai acquis beaucoup
d'expérience et de sagesse
c'était le coup fatal quoi donc je suis
super content ce qui a fait la
différence la sagesse l'expérience va se
situer la sagesse surtout le côté calme
aux halles il était sur un gars comme
moi je suis énervé dans la difficulté
même quand on nous a défoncés en bas
soit c'est un gros mental c'est cette
année leur appui et à ne pas y arriver
mais tout peut se jouer la preuve on
gagne l'étape s'en remet à la ville a
donc encore moins avoir été vraiment
formidable super retour là où les
avaient suivis en tout cas tout le loin
durant ces sept jours oui tout à fait et
c'est normand
donc c'est vrai que je lui ai apporté
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup mais sous
très fort ice hôtel
merci à tous merci beaucoup